على ضفتين هرباخ موت تستعير المعارك بين
المقاومين الاوكران وقوات فاكنر الروسيه
لكن التقدم متوقف وبحاجه لمغامره من
المهاجمين قد تكون نتائجها وخيمه النهر
الذي يقطع المدينه من المنتصف تحول الى خط
مواجهه شرقه تتمركز قوات فاغندا بينما
يتمترس الاوكرانيون غربه وما بينهما حولته
كثافه النيران الى ساحه للقتل والموت وفقا
لتقرير صادر عن وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
فان المحاولات الروسيه مستمره لتطويق
المقاومين الاوكرانيين حيث يحاولوا
المهاجمون تطويق المدينه من ثلاث جهات لكن
تكتيك كييف في تدمير الجسور والطرق شكل
تحديا كبيرا امام المهاجمين اضافه لنيران
القناصه الاوكرانيين من جهه الغرب
قوات فاجنر التي تقود الهجوم على باخموت
ومع التقدم الضئيل في الميدان تشتكي من
قله الذخيره والتسليح امر يضيف تحديا
جديدا في وجهها
هذا مبنى اداره المدينه هذا هو وسط
المدينه على بعد مسافه كيلو متر و200 متر
اهم شيء الان هو الحصول على الذخيره
والمضي قدما في معركه باخمت المستمره منذ
قرابه الثمانيه شهور بدا حساب الفارق بين
النصر والهزيمه بالامتار لكنها امتار بنهر
من النار والجحيم رائد المصطفى العربيه